In today’s world, the results of scientific
research need to get out to the public domain
as soon as possible, partly because academia has
become highly competitive and authors need to show
their recent work for the purposes of funding, job
applications, and career progression in general.
Besides, timely dissemination of research results
is required to accelerate scientific progress.
This is particularly important in some
fields such as biology and medicine,
where it can influence healthcare related
developments, decisions, and policies; and in
computer science and information technology, where
the pace of scientific progress is very fast.
The need to share research findings immediately
and the growing frustration of scientists
at the slow pace of academic journals has
led to the trend of distributing preprints.
What is a preprint?
A preprint is a completed
draft of a scientific manuscript that is
uploaded by the author on a public server;
often it is the same version of the
manuscript that is submitted to a journal.
Once the manuscript is uploaded, it goes through a
quick check to ascertain that it is scientific in
nature. It is then posted online within a day
or two without peer review and is made freely
available for everyone to view. Revised versions
of the same manuscript can be uploaded later on,
but the older versions also remain.
Popular preprints servers in different fields
There are several sites that host preprints,
often known as preprint servers or repositories.
While some of the preprint severs
host papers from various disciplines,
others cater only to selected disciplines. The
oldest and most popular one is arXiv which was
created back in the 1990s for distributing
physics preprints. The site currently hosts
papers from various disciplines such as physics,
mathematics, computer science, and statistics.
The main players in the field of the life sciences
are bioRxiv and PeerJ PrePrints. Nature also has a
preprint server, Nature Precedings, for biology,
medicine, chemistry, and earth science papers.
Social science and humanities preprints can
be posted on Social Science Research Network.
Some of the benefits of publishing
a preprint may include :
No delays : The most obvious benefit of using
preprints is that it removes the element of
delay in the journal publication process, and
others can benefit from your work immediately .
Open access : Depositing your work in
a preprint server is a great way to
make your research freely available
to all scientists across the world.
This is also known as green open access .
Establish priority : At a time when many
scientists across the world might be working on
the same research idea, putting up a preprint
can help establish your priority on an idea or
discovery as preprint servers generally mention
the date on which the article was posted .
Receive valuable feedback on your work :
Once you have posted a preprint, you can send
the link to fellow scientists asking for their
feedback. Sometimes, scientists spot an error in
your paper and comment on it. You can use such
feedback to judge the quality of your work and
improve it before you submit it to a journal.
This will increase its chances of
getting accepted by the journal .
Get early attention : Papers posted on
preprints servers are usually citable,
and thus, you stand a chance of being cited even
before your paper is published in a journal.
If scientists like your study, they
might even share it on social media.
Thus, you can get attention for your research
even before it is officially published .
Provide evidence of your research : Funding
agencies and hiring committees often want to
see evidence of your recent work. Thus, delays
in publishing can be extremely damaging when you
are applying for grants or for a job. Preprints
are extremely useful under such circumstances .
Increase chances of collaboration and invitations
to meetings : Conference and seminar organizers
are often on the lookout for people to
present work that has not yet been published.
A preprint increases your visibility
and can attract meeting organizers
as well as potential collaborators .
and, Gain visibility for a broad range
of findings : Novelty is often a prime
criterion for being published in a journal.
Thus, it can be difficult for authors to
publish null findings or replication studies.
Preprints eliminate this problem by providing
visibility to a much broader range of findings .
However , there are Some concerns about preprints.
The most important concern that the
scientific community has about preprints
is that they are not peer reviewed. Peer review
is an essential quality control mechanism to
weed out essentially flawed or poor quality
studies. Additionally, without peer review,
there is a possibility of incorrect information
reaching the general public through preprints.
This can be potentially harmful in areas such
as climate science or vaccine safety. Thus,
some kinds of work may not be appropriate for
dissemination through preprints. Another possible
problem is that scientists might upload articles
or findings prematurely just to claim priority.